Prof: So today we're
going to engage Modernism.
We're going to be talking
principally about the music of
Igor Stravinsky.
I should also mention Arnold
Schoenberg.
Just as Verdi and Wagner were
the principal composers of opera
in the nineteenth century,
so Schoenberg and Stravinsky
were the principal proponents--
not only of instrumental music,
but some vocal music--
in the first half of the
twentieth century.
So we want to keep them
carefully positioned on our
radar screen here.
Igor Stravinsky,
of course, was a Russian
composer, born in St.
Petersburg.
You have the dates up there on
the board, I'm sure.
He studied with Nikolai
Rimsky-Korsakov,
who wrote one famous piece,
Scheherazade--
which I used to hear all the
time as a kid--
and then caught the eye of
Sergei Diaghilev.
Serge Diaghilev was an
impresario.
What's an impresario?
Who can tell me what an
impresario is?
It's a fancy word for--Thaddeus.
Student: A producer.
Prof: A producer. Okay.
Think of the Broadway show
"The Producers."
He's simply a producer.
And what Diaghilev was
producing and importing into
Paris from Russia was Modernist
art from Russia--
Modernist painting,
Modernist ballet,
Modernist art music,
and Modernist opera.
So that's what we want to keep
in mind with regard to Sergei
Diaghilev.
And for Diaghilev,
Stravinsky composed,
early in his career,
three important ballet scores,
and you have those titles up on
the board there:
Firebird with its date--
what?
1909--Petrushka,
1911, and then The Rite of
Spring in 1913.
Now, the first of these ballets
to really show a heavy Modernist
content is not so much
Firebird but more the
second of this troika here,
Petrushka.
It's modern because of the new
approach to rhythm.
In the Romantic music that we
have been listening to,
we would hear these long,
somewhat amorphous melodies,
amorphous in terms of the
rhythm.
But now here with the advent of
Modernism in the twentieth
century we get a much more
driving type of rhythm.
It almost in some ways goes
back to the driving rhythms of
the Baroque except with one
major difference,
and that is that these modern
rhythms are highly irregular.
What we get oftentimes are
irregular meters.
What would you imagine an
irregular meter is?
Anyone want to field that one,
irregular meters?
Well, simply said,
it's not a succession of
two-four,
two-four, two-four,
two-four or three-four,
three-four, but two-four,
five-four,
four-four, two-four,
six-four, three-eight,
and so on.
Each measure can have a
different meter.
In addition,
we also have this phenomenon
called polymeters in which you
could assign to your clarinet to
play in three- four and your
bassoon to play in four-four,
and maybe your violins in
seven-eight.
So as a result,
you get something of a
disjunctive, rhythmic texture
here, disjointed rhythms.
And the second aspect of this
approach to Modernism has
something to do with the
orchestration.
There's a great deal more
emphasis now on percussive
effects.
New instruments are added to
the orchestra,
instruments called the
xylophone, the glockenspiel,
the celesta.
And if you want to see a
picture of some of these you
could open your textbook at some
point--
just write this in your
notes--see figure--
I think I wrote it down
here--figure ten--
no, excuse me--five,
number ten, chapter five,
number ten.
You can see some of these
percussion instruments,
but basically they're just
either sticks or pieces of metal
bars that you beat with sticks,
or, in the case of the celesta,
you activate with a keyboard.
So we've got these two things
here: driving but irregular
rhythms and we also have this
new approach to orchestration.
So let's listen to a bit now of
Igor Stravinsky's ballet of
1911, Petrushka.
>
Can you conduct this?
Jacob and I were fooling around
with this in the background,
trying to figure out what these
meters were,
see if we could pick up these
different changes,
but they are as--and how'd we
do?
Not well.
Jacob says we did not do well.
Because without the score,
it's difficult to anticipate
which meter is going to come
next.
And you heard the intense
percussive effects there.
But Stravinsky's most radical
statement of Modernism occurs
not here in
"Petrushka"
but two years later in The
Rite of Spring.
It premiered in Paris in May of
1913, and it's become something
of a cultural icon,
this whole idea of the Rite
of Spring.
Indeed I have this book,
and I've had it for quite a
while, Rites of Spring by
Modris Eksteins.
It's often required reading in
the history department here,
history program.
Has anybody ever run into this,
been asked to read anything by
Modris Eksteins?
Well, the subtitle is here:
The Great War and the Birth
of the Modern Age,
but it's not accidental
that he is playing off of this
title of a ballet of Igor
Stravinsky,
because the ballet of
Stravinsky was a kind of
watershed,
a touchstone,
the benchmark from which
Modernism can be calculated and
against which it can be
measured.
So when the audience arrived
there at the Theatre
Champs-Elysees in Paris--and
that theatre still is there.
You can walk down the Avenue
Montagne--it's where Hermes is
and Gucci and all of these fancy
stores;
it's there in Paris--and go in
and still hear concerts there.
I've heard concerts in the
Theatre Champs-Elysees so
you can still do that today.
It's still functioning.
It's one of the major concert
halls in Paris.
So, in any event,
May 1913, the audience arrives.
They are there to hear a
Russian ballet.
What kind of music do they
expect to hear?
Well, let's listen to what they
were expecting to hear.
>
So whose music is this?
Student: Tchaikovsky.
Prof: Tchaikovsky.
Anybody--Leah,
you know the title of it?
"Swan Lake,"
so lots of tutus and pas de
deux up there and moving
around.
So this is what they thought
Russian ballet was.
So they arrive and take their
seats.
The lights go down.
Everybody is properly dressed
for this particular occasion and
here is the kind of music that
they hear.
>
So that's a radically new
sound, a radically new approach
to modern art,
and indeed, once again,
if you ask,
generally, cultural historians
to put their finger on the
moment that constitutes the
beginning of Modernism it would
probably be this moment of the
performance of The Rite of
Spring.
How did Stravinsky create these
radically new sounds?
Well, he did so in a couple of
ways.
We've been talking before about
this idea of irregular meters.
Let's see how these play out.
The music that you were just
listening to--
not the pitches but the
durations--are up here on the
board,
and they're all,
as you can see,
quarter notes,
but they are grouped in
different sorts of ways,
grouped by these accents.
So I've asked Jacob--Jacob's up
here--to grab his viola now.
He's going to come over and
play the sequence for us
following the accents,
and then he will be joined by
our guest artist.
>
Okay. So that's the way it goes.
That's all the violin--or the
violist or violinist,
all the strings do.
Let's do that one more time
with our guest artist.
We're going to add percussion
now.
>
Ah, what a virtuoso duo.
Okay.
So that was--Jacob,
don't go away completely here.
One other point:
watch Jacob's hand when he is
doing this.
This is not the way string
players normally play.
He's doing something
extraordinary here and it tells
us--we don't hear--when you play
Tchaikovsky
>
, but that ain't what he's
playing now.
>
Okay. So what's he doing?
He's playing all with--
Student: Down bows.
Prof: Down bows,
everything down bow,
and that's counterintuitive to
your normal string teaching.
So we've taken these string
instruments and instead of using
them as these warm,
vibrato-filled communicators
we're--
in the string family we're sort
of turning them in now to
percussion instruments.
That's a very percussive effect.
So not only do we have new
percussion instruments;
we have percussive effects with
the existing instruments.
And perhaps most important here
is the chord,
the music that Stravinsky is
setting forth here.
It's an odd chord.
It's an odd occurrence.
What he's got here is a
perfectly innocuous E major
triad.
>
I'll put it down here an octave.
And then on top of it he's got
a seventh chord starting on
E-flat.
>
And either--each of those--each
by itself is rather consonant,
but you put the two of them
together <<plays
piano>>.
So this is a good example of
another way that Modernism in
music is created,
and that's for the use of,
very obviously,
a polychord.
Interesting point.
I'm going to go to some slides
now because it's exactly at this
time in the history of art that
painters started doing this same
kind of thing.
So we're going to go to the
first slide here.
Who painted this, please?
Student:
>
Prof: Nice and loud.
I hear it in the back.
Student: Picasso.
Prof: Picasso. Okay.
"Three Musicians"
by Pablo Picasso.
And what we have here is sort
of one musician kind of out of
phase with himself--
one musician and then another
musician slightly in an
irregular position against that.
Next type of slide here:
This is Georges Braque,
"Woman with Violin,"
a little bit difficult to see
the woman there in the context
of this highly fragmented
violin.
Now we're going to go on to
Juan Gris' "Violin"
and now we're going to go on to
a slide taken from a book
published in 1916by Albert
Gleizes.
But we can see the point here.
Off to the left we have just a
square.
And that square then is being
rotated against itself.
It's being rotated
itself--against itself in
another position,
rotated itself in yet another
position, and that's all these
musicians are doing.
They're taking one triad and
then taking the triad right next
to each other so the triads are
slightly out of phase with each
other.
And ultimately it produces a
rather dissonant configuration.
Okay.
That's all we need here by way
of the slides.
Well, the premiere of The
Rite of Spring was just as
dissonant as some of these
paintings are.
Indeed, it caused a scandal.
It caused a riot.
It created the most infamous--I
guess--
riot in the history of music,
and we have,
fortunately,
and they are contained here in
Modris Eksteins's book among
other places,
some primary source
accounts--people who were there
at the time telling what it was
like to be at this premiere.
So here are a couple of direct
quotes.
"Then ensued a battery of
screams countered by a foil of
applause.
We warred over art."
I like that:
"warred over art."
"Or what some thought was
art but others didn't.
About forty of the protesters
were forced out of the theater
by the police,
but that did not quell the
disturbance.
The lights in the auditorium
were turned fully on,
but that did not still the
disjointed ravings of a mob of
angry men and women."
End quote.
And here's another direct
quote.
"I was sitting in a box in
which I had rented one seat.
Three ladies sat in front of me
and a young man occupied the
place behind me.
He stood up during the course
of the ballet to see more
clearly.
The intense excitement under
which he was laboring,
thanks to the potent force of
the music,
portrayed itself presently when
he began to beat rhythmically
with his fists on the top of my
head."
>
End quote.
Well, what is it,
again, specifically in this
music of Stravinsky that causes
this kind of reaction?
Let me list for you--let me
enumerate five things here.
One: heavy dissonance.
We just heard some of that,
>
that kind of sound,
almost a cluster-type
dissonance,
heavy dissonance created by
polychords in which we have
triads and these triads are only
a half step apart.
The roots are only a half step
apart.
So one: heavy dissonance.
Two: much greater reliance on
percussion: tympani,
glockenspiel,
celesta, that sort of thing.
Three: as we saw with Jacob,
the use of stringed instruments
as percussion instruments,
so a new use of these
traditional instruments,
and even the piano,
this banging on the piano.
The percussion--the piano is
technically a percussion
instrument but it's a
particularly lyrical one.
Well, it's not so lyrically
used here in the modern idiom.
Number four:
an increased use of woodwinds.
The strings fall into the
background.
The woodwinds with their
potentially bright,
brittle sound are now
foregrounded.
And fifth: this idea of rhythm,
driving rhythms,
yes, but irregular rhythms and
polymeters and irregular meters
all creating this kind of
disjunctive effect.
So let's listen now to a
passage out of Stravinsky's
Rite of Spring.
You heard one of them.
Let's listen to another one in
which all five of these elements
sound at once.
>
So what do you think?
Do you like that music?
Brian, you've been a good
student here.
You've shown up virtually every
lecture.
I see you out there.
What do you think of this?
Is this--
Student: Well,
it's different--
Prof: It's different?
Student: Different than
the Mozart, more fast paced.
Prof: More fast paced,
more sort of upbeat,
kind of like a slap in the
face.
Who doesn't like it?
End--okay.
Caroline, honest person out
there.
She doesn't like it.
At the end of the day,
are you going to go home when
it's time to relax and put on
this music?
Probably not.
Do I like this music?
Yeah, I really do like this
music.
I love this music but I've
heard it a lot,
and when I first heard it I
didn't like it.
It's one of these things like
sort of aural spinach or
whatever.
You've got to really get used
to it over the years,
mushrooms or whatever it might
happen to be.
I first heard this piece in
nineteen sixty-seven,
when I was a TA.
I had to teach it and I didn't
really know it,
and then I had the honor and
pleasure of hearing it performed
live in Paris in 1970.
And it was really an epiphany
because I was sitting there--I
remember it distinctly.
It was in a boxing arena,
of all places,
but they had an elevated stage
and the dancers came out and
they started going
>
, that kind of thing,
and the whole arena began to
shake and I said,
"Whoa.
I now understand. I get it.
It's not just the music.
Music is just part of this
total artistic experience.
It's a kind of sympathetic
vibration in conjunction with
the kinetic experience of the
dance that really brings all of
this to life."
So music here is just a kind of
catalyst for the ballet and to
really begin to appreciate
something such as this,
Stravinsky's approach to
Modernism,
we've kind of--we do,
in fact--have to see it to
experience it fully.
And that's really what we're
going to do here next.
We're going to do that in
section starting today.
We have a wonderful video for
you of the reconstruction of
The Rite of Spring
because the initial
choreography,
which is an important part of
this, was lost.
So a woman choreographer came
along,
Millicent Hodson,
and she reconstructed all the
choreography for this dance and
then they filmed it so this is a
wonderful opportunity to see
this.
We'll be talking about this in
section starting today.
Okay.
We're finished with our brief
introduction to Modernism and
where do we stand now in our
course?
Well, obviously we're pretty
much at the end of it.
What do you have to do--what
remains for you to do?
Zach, what do you got to do?
Student: My last paper.
Prof: You got to do your
last paper.
Each TA will assign that last
paper.
What else do you have to do?
Student: Prepare for the
final exam.
Prof: Prepare for the
We will be sending you a prep
sheet.
The final exam I believe is
Wednesday, the seventeenth,
at two p.m.
and will be in this room.
Other things?
Student:
>
Prof: Yeah,
the last six Listening
Exercises, and I think that's
about it.
And, of course,
in addition there's a review
section that I and one or two of
the TAs will be doing a week
from today right back in here.
So is that the end of today?
No, that's not the end of today.
We have a good half hour left
and I'd like to work just with
one piece and one composer.
At the end of the course,
I like to do a piece that's
really--that I love.
It doesn't really teach you
much of anything.
It's an odd sensation.
Oftentimes there are really
lovely pieces that I would like
to incorporate in the textbook
and in this program generally
but I can't do it because they
don't really teach us anything.
We were listening to one in
section, this intro music,
the other day by Samuel Barber.
Anybody know who wrote a famous
piece--or what the name of that
famous piece by Samuel Barber
is?
Thaddeus, Elizabeth, Raoul.
Student: "The
Adagio"
Prof: "The Adagio
of--for Strings"
by Samuel Barber,
American--it's beautiful.
We should--everybody should
download it for ninety-nine
cents.
It's just gorgeous,
but we don't really learn
anything from it.
Well, this is a piece that
we--we're about to hear that we
will learn only really one thing
about, and that is the idea of
an orchestral Lied.
So I'm going to go back to one
of my favorite composers and
that is Gustav Mahler.
We talked a little bit about
Gustav Mahler when we had our
lecture on the symphony in the
nineteenth century,
and we said that Mahler was of
Jewish descent,
from what is now a portion of
the Czech Republic,
who came in to Vienna to study
music.
He started as a pianist,
became a conductor,
and basically he earned his
living as a conductor.
He got small-time jobs out in
the provinces and then
ultimately worked his way back
to Vienna,
where he became the conductor
of the Staatsoper in
Vienna,
and if you ever go to
Vienna--and you should all go to
Vienna.
It's an incredibly musical city.
Everywhere you go you see these
silhouettes of Mozart.
It is so cool.
So you have to go to--you can't
walk a block without seeing
Mozart.
It's to die for.
So there we are on the
Ringstrasse with the
great Staatsoper,
and this is where Gustav Mahler
conducted and it's still there,
but Mahler was a difficult
person to get along with.
I suppose oftentimes great
artists are, geniuses are.
They tend to be
self-referential and maybe
rightly so, but in any event,
he was an orchestral tyrant.
His players didn't like playing
for them, and after ten years
they didn't renew his contract.
In effect, he was fired in
Vienna but,
as good fortune had it,
he was able--
or at that time there was an
opening in New York City so he
comes to New York to conduct
first the Metropolitan Opera and
then a year or so later he took
on what was to become the New
York Philharmonic.
So there he is,
the principal conductor,
now in New York City.
Interestingly enough,
on two occasions Mahler came to
New Haven.
He came to New Haven.
He brought--first was in 1910,
he brought the New York
Philharmonic to New Haven and
where did they perform?
Where would you imagine they'd
perform?
Woolsey Hall. Okay?
Woolsey Hall.
Woolsey Hall was built for
Gustav Mahler.
No.
That's not really true,
but it gets across a point:
that Woolsey Hall was built to
be a concert hall for what
Gustav Mahler represented,
which was the apotheosis,
the ultimate flourishing,
although they didn't know it
was the ultimate at the time,
of this great instrument,
which was the
nineteenth-century orchestra.
So Mahler brings the New York
Philharmonic to Woolsey Hall.
The next time you're in Woolsey
Hall, think of Gustav Mahler
standing on those boards there.
And, as good luck would have it
again, the concert was reviewed
in of all places,
as you can see by the handout
for today, The Yale Daily.
How about that?
The Yale Daily
>
reviews Gustav Mahler,
astonishing.
Okay, astonishing.
And I didn't--darn it--I didn't
bring my glasses today,
but you can sort of look at the
review there and it talks about
the repertoire.
What did he perform?
First of all,
they slightly misspelled his
name.
There's no "e"
on Gustav in the way he spelled
it, but that doesn't really
matter.
What did they perform at this
concert conducted by Mahler in
Woolsey Hall?
What's it say there? Elizabeth.
Student: Symphonie
fantastique--
Prof: Okay,
Symphonie fantastique,
the basis of what?
Your Listening Exercise 34.
Okay?
So that was one of the big
pieces, the ones that you have
just engaged.
What else, please?
Student: Bach's suites.
Prof: Okay.
Bach orchestral suite.
It doesn't say which one.
It doesn't matter.
What else?
Student: Strauss's
>
Prof: Yeah. That's good.
Till Eulenspiegel's Merry
Pranks.
That's another one of these
tone poems,
like Zarathusta, and
like Death and
Transfiguration, by Strauss,
and there was also a pianist
there,
and what did she perform,
Olga Samaroff?
Student: Grieg
>
Prof: Yeah,
the Grieg Piano Concerto.
But no music by Mahler,
because in his day Mahler was
thought to really be more of a
conductor than he was a
composer.
We'll come back to that point
in a minute.
The second time that Mahler
came to New Haven was the next
year, 1911.
He went to what was then called
New Haven Hospital.
Why?
Because he had a heart
condition.
And I gather--and we have in
our midst today a specialist who
can talk to this more directly
than I--
a streptococcal infection,
a lingering streptococcal
infection in the area of the
heart that had greatly weakened
his heart so the doctors at
Yale-New Haven Hospital--
New Haven Hospital said,
"There's really nothing we
can do for you."
He goes back to New York,
goes immediately back to Vienna
and he dies within six weeks of
this heart condition.
And we have--and I'm delighted
to say Dr. James Hines has
been with us all semester.
Jim, thank you for your
attendance--a cardiologist.
He has been here.
You may have thought that this
was just accidental,
but in case--I was thinking
this morning.
We've never told you that we
had--if your heart begins to
palpitate when you're listening
to all this really great music
and you become aphasic or
something like that,
we have an attendant here ready
to serve you in the form of
Dr. Hines.
So you've been in good hands
all along and thank you,
Jim, for being here.
So let's take a look at some of
the things that Gustav Mahler
composed here,
and I think we've got a list up
on the board.
Okay.
Symphonies: nine symphonies.
Why is it that everybody
composes nine symphonies and
then they die--
>
--stop at eight.
No.
He composed also nine
symphonies.
He composed nine symphonies and
if you like Mahler,
and I hope you will come to
like Mahler, I think there's an
entry path into these
symphonies.
Start with number four.
It's the most user friendly,
then number one.
We played two tracks out of
number one in that symphony
lecture so you know that it's a
great piece too.
Then Symphony number five,
which is worth the price of
admission, really,
if for no other reason than the
middle movement there.
That Adagietto is just
so heartbreakingly beautiful
that no one would want to miss
it,
and then ultimately a little
bit more challenging symphonies,
bigger symphonies:
number eight and number nine.
Mahler also wrote,
as you can see up there,
two collections of songs.
They're called orchestral
Lieder.
We have this orchestral Lied.
It simply means orchestral song.
We've had the Lied before in
our course.
Where?
Indeed, what was the name of
the Lied that we worked with?
Composer's name,
the name of the piece?
Hm?
Student:
>
Prof: Okay. That's it.
What was the name of the piece?
Student:
>
Prof: "The Elf
King." Thank you,
Frederick.
And who was the composer?
Student:
>
Prof: Franz Schubert.
Okay.
So we've had a--that's a Lied
for piano but now we have a Lied
for voice and orchestra,
so it tends to be bigger and
more flamboyant.
This is a new genre.
It's longer,
it's more colorful,
yet it features a single voice
singing a single text.
So we're going to focus
on--now--on one of Gustav
Mahler's orchestral Lieds,
and it's talked about in the
textbook there right before
Impressionism.
No Listening Exercise on it
and, as I say,
it's in there just because I
think it's a drop-dead beautiful
piece and I want to try to
proselytize a bit with regard to
Mahler's music so it has a text.
Here's the text.
The text is by romantic German
poet Friedrich Ruckert.
We're now talking about
"Ich bin der Welt abhanden
gekommen"
by Friedrich Ruckert as set in
this collection of five songs
about 1902.
And let's take a look at the
German here just for a moment,
"Ich bin der Welt abhanden
gekommen,"
"I've become detached from
the world."
And I thought it'd be nice to
hear a German speaker,
or somebody that speaks pretty
good German,
tackle this text so I've asked
a student,
David Narotsky to stand up,
if you would.
David's applying to med school.
Right?
You're going around for all
kinds of med school interviews
but here he's putting on his
German hat for us this morning.
So read the first strophe,
please, David.
Student: <<speaks
German>>
Prof: Okay.
Let's cut to the last one and a
little bit more slowly and a
little--because it slows down.
So let's read it a little more
slowly.
Student: <<speaks
German>>
Prof: Okay.
Great.
Thanks very much.
So, as you can see here,
this is, in a sense,
old person's music in that this
is an individual that has become
disenchanted--
is exhausted from the trials
and tribulations of this world.
There's that sense of "Ich
bin der Welt abhanden
gekommen,"
I've become detached from the
world and if you don't see much
of me anymore I don't really
care because,
as it says in the last strophe,
"Ich bin gestorben dem
Weltgetümmel,"
I'm dead to the tumult I guess
of the world,
"und ruh' in einem stillen
Gebiet,"
and I rest now in a still land,
"ich leb' allein,"
I'm living alone in my
heaven,"
"in meinem Lieben,
in meinem Lied,"
and there it's an interesting
play of the word Lied because
it's not so much a song.
This is a metaphor for all of
his music so this is an
individual that has become
detached from the world and
simply wants to live in the
world of music.
So let's listen to a bit of it
now.
And it starts out with an
English horn.
Somebody tell us,
review for us,
what an English horn is--talked
about this before.
Jerry.
Student:
>
Prof: A lower oboe.
That's right,
a lower oboe,
and it sounds a little bit
mournful,
sounds a little bit nostalgic
here,
so we hear a lovely harp
underneath and then the English
horn will start with just one
phrase and then that phrase will
grow.
It's kind of a cell or a motive
growing into a longer melody as
we discussed in the beginning of
the course.
It's an interesting song in
that--I'm going to vamp here
just for a moment.
It starts out with the harp
underneath and the English horn,
and it's a movement in which
there is no brass whatsoever.
So I believe we have it set up
now.
It's not to be an exciting
movement, much more of a
reflective movement.
>
Passes off the melody to a
clarinet <<music
playing>>
and then the voice will come in.
>
Okay.
We're going to pause it there.
Then we will go on to a little
bit of material from the climax
of the song just by way of a
preview here.
We're going to go on now to
4'47",
if you will,
where he works up to a peak on
this text,
"Ich leb' allein in meinem
Himmel,
in meinem Lieben,
in meinem Lied."
>
A little bit of dissonance,
back to the tonic,
English horn comes back in,
builds out the melody.
>
Okay.
Now we're going to pause it
here because there's one other
small point that I want to make
and that has to do with
a--what's called a suspension.
A suspension is something that
composers set up in music to
sort of make us feel a
particular way,
and they'll start with this by
having a note be consonant
>
and then having--moving the
harmony underneath of it
>
to a dissonance and then
resolving it to a consonant
like that or maybe <<plays
piano>>.
And the longer they sit on the
dissonance, the more feeling,
I think, is communicated.
And here at the end of the
Romantic period it tends to
be--they tend to sit on these
dissonances inside of the
suspension for a long period of
time.
So we're about to hear--We're
about to hear the strings go up
and play a suspension and then
the English horn will do the
same.
There it is <<music
playing>>.
Now the English horn will
suspend, <<music
playing>>
dissonance <<music
playing>>.
Okay. So that's the piece.
Now we're going to do something
we've only done on one other
occasion in the class and that
is to listen to the whole piece
from beginning to end.
I'd like to do this and it may
be a little hokey I guess,
but it doesn't matter.
I'm going to turn off all the
lights here as best I can,
and I do this because it gives
you a sense,
sometimes, of what--at least
how I engage music oftentimes--
what does it do for us?
Well, we've talked before at
the beginning.
It allows us to kind of relax,
center our attention.
You're under a lot of stress at
the moment.
This is the sort of climax,
crunch time,
in the academic world so this
is an opportunity to kind of
tune everything out,
maybe go inside of your own
Gebiet here,
your own musical territory,
and maybe think of things in
the past,
music as a creator of
nostalgia, think of things that
might be,
music giving us a vision
perhaps of a better world,
whatever you'd like--whatever
spin you want to put on this,
but we're going to be--each of
us is now going to go into our
own zone here for about seven
minutes as we listen to this
orchestral Lied,
"Ich bin der Welt abhanden
gekommen,"
by Gustav Mahler.
>
Okay.
So that's our last piece of
music for Listening to Music
here.
Now I'm going to tell you what
this class was really about.
>
It wasn't about listening to
music.
It was about saving classical
Why?
Why would we want to save
classical music?
We could spend hours discussing
that.
We would want to save it,
arguably, because it is one of
the things that we value in
Western culture.
What do we value?
I was thinking about this,
this morning.
We've got--we just had a big
election.
Right? We value democracy.
We value religious freedom.
We value equality of the sexes,
of gender.
What else?
Due process under the law.
We value Shakespeare.
We value Leonardo da Vinci and
the symphonies of Mozart for
example,
and these are very important
things and I think they're worth
fighting for and worth trying to
preserve.
Recently, somebody gave the
School of Music how much money?
One hundred million dollars to
keep classical music alive.
That's a lot of money.
I've done my part,
showed up here every day,
haven't missed a minute.
Now it's time for you to do
your part.
What's your part?
You have to do the following
kinds of things.
You have to continue to buy CDs
and download classical music off
of iTunes or whatever it is.
Don't steal that stuff.
Why?
If you take that stuff for
nothing, what are you doing?
You're taking the livelihood
away from Jacob and Santana and
Lynda here, just the livelihood
of musicians.
They've put their labor into it
and you're taking it for
nothing.
So download these things.
It doesn't cost all that much.
Two: get involved.
Get involved in informal
singing groups,
keep your piano lessons,
if you've ever had those kinds
of things going on,
local choral groups,
whatever.
You get out of Yale.
What do you do?
Get on the boards of these
artistic institutions,
your local symphony,
your local choral society,
opera company,
Neighborhood Music School here.
Get on the board of that and
help them, those sorts of folks.
Most important,
give music lessons to your
children, adopted or natural.
Why?
Teaches them hard work,
teaches them to think
sequentially,
teaches them various forms of
quantitative reasoning,
teaches them also to be
disciplined and teaches them to
have a pride in the work product
that they ultimately generate.
So these are the kinds of
things that you can do.
I thank you for your attention.
I thank you--I thank the TAs
for doing such a wonderful--and
we've had great TAs this year.
And so I will end by quoting
here Gustav Mahler once again,
to share with you "meinem
Lieben,
und meinem Lied,"
because it really is.
Thanks very much.